you know there was research that was
done I think just before the pandemic
that showed that 42 percent of amount
American households and 42 percent of
American households uh the female
Partners out earning the male partner
and so we've entered into a space where
in almost half of American households
the woman is the primary Breadwinner and
so roles have shifted you know Financial
uh the way that things look within the
household has shifted but I think our
capacity to have the conversations in
terms of the the role that stress plays
I think it plays a role in many
different things I'm gonna just approach
this by breaking down what actually
happens within our body because I think
I didn't actually know this I don't
think most people actually know this you
know you have two branches to your
autonomic nervous system you have your
uh sympathetic and your parasympathetic
right your sympathetic is like the gas
pedal so that's what happens when you're
getting stuff done when you're working
when you're working out it's tied to
your fight flight or freeze response so
when conflict happens or you feel more
stressed out you're in this state and
your body has a very specific response
when you're in that sympathetic response
state right so your uh your breath per
minute goes up so you're actually
breathing faster your heart rate goes up
right so your body's working a little
bit harder your body's releasing more
cortisol more adrenaline depending on
how stressed that you actually are and
then on the other side of the spectrum
is your parasympathetic which is like
the brake pedal right so that's
responsible for rest digest being calm
feeling peaceful Etc
interesting fact that most people don't
know is that in order for a man to be
aroused
in order for a man to get an erection he
has to be in a parasympathetic dominant
state within his nervous system
so he actually has to be in a more
restful more calm digestive state in
order to get aroused so a lot of the
non-medical erectile dysfunction
problems that happen a lot of the
non-medical premature ejaculation
challenges that men face is not because
there's something physically going wrong
besides the fact that they can't get out
of that stress State they literally
cannot move their body out of this place
of the breath is going really fast their
heart rate is elevated their body's
releasing cortisol stress hormones
adrenaline Etc and then it gets worse
too the more time you spend in
sympathetic the harder it is to get into
parasympathetic right that's right
that's right yeah so your body sort of
acclimatizes to this like go go go you
know maxed out always on State and it
becomes hard for a man to feel regulated
to feel grounded right there's a lot of
terms that get thrown around out there
but it becomes hard for a man's body
body and mind to move out of this stress
State and into a relaxed state so what
do we do right we turn to things like
alcohol which is a suppressant we turn
to things like weed which is supposed to
help us calm down well there's a lot of
research now coming out that if you're a
chronic user which is more than twice a
week of smoking weed that over uh along
over a period of time that can actually
increase your level of Stress and
Anxiety you can actually deregulate your
body and your nervous system even more
so Andrew huberman has some great
research on that wow and and so we turn
to porn right porn is probably the
number one way that men try to regulate
their nervous system to feel relaxed to
feel calm because after you watch porn
after you ejaculate your body a man's
body will actually release things like
dopamine so you feel good oxytocin the
bonding chemical and then something
called prolactin
which in women is response responsible
for something very different but for men
it's actually a calming down agent so
it's a neurochemical that gets released
and says to a male body you should calm
down you should relax a little bit so
it's why a lot of men after getting off
they feel a little bit sleepy they feel
tired their body moves into this very
like restful stage right so so this
level of stress occupying this territory
um causes us to largely feel
more insecure
struggle to make more concrete decisions
create Direction vision for our life
have challenging conversations right go
through conflict in a healthy way which
is incredibly important for any
relationship right the number one uh
thing that any relationship needs to to
do is to get through conflict in a
healthy positive way to come out the
other side okay so what we need as human
beings and so all of these things become
more challenging right focusing on your
task it can you know increase ADHD so
stress is a huge challenge for a lot of
people and so we and and the problem is
is that we live in a society that
prioritizes medication versus meditation
well I mean people use people use
marijuana for medication to like go to
sleep right
yeah and you know I think again
the literature on that is uh not great
you know like
because the THC content we probably
don't need to go down this path to too
much but because the THC content has
been like wildly dialed up uh for a lot
of people over time what will start to
happen
is that it actually replaces you know it
binds with a CB1 receptor in your brain
which is the the primary receptor to
your nervous system
and so it actually starts to replace
your body's natural process of of
regulating and so you start to create
this little bit of a dependency on it to
feel like you're calm and grounded and
de-stressed and that can feel good for a
while but for the majority of people
what will start to happen is if they're
using more than twice a week for a
prolonged period of time is that that
will wear off and they'll actually start
to feel more anxious
especially if you don't use it right if
you don't use it you lose it that's good
that's good
what are the good releases what can a
man do for Relief instead of turning to
something like porn instead of turning
to alcohol instead of turning to
cheating instead of turning to react
overreacting to things like instead of
doing those things or avoiding leaving
the home whatever that that that that
may be what are healthy
forms of relief or release
so there are some very basic things
right there's some very basic things I
think you know if you listen to podcast
if you're somebody that listens to
podcasts quite a bit you've probably
heard this big push on most health
people's podcasts to uh cold immersion
right to sort of like cold therapy to uh
saunas to breath work and there's a
reason for that your breath is the
primary
um
the the primary thing that can actually
impact the dial between your stressed
part of your nervous system and your
relaxed part of your nervous system
right so if you're really stressed out
you're very anxious because there's
almost no difference from a neurological
stance between Stress and Anxiety
they're they're almost the same
neurologically right in terms of the
chemicals that get released and how your
nervous system is operating Etc so your
breath is the pathway that can help you
move out of that stressed state so if
you use very specific breathing
exercises right one of them is called
the Box breath which has been very
popularized right so you inhale for a
count of four you pause for a count of
four you exhale for a count to four and
you pause for a count of four and you do
that box cycle for about five minutes
and when you do that you're regulating
your breath cycle to such a degree where
you're sending a signal to your heart to
slow down so as you regulate your breath
your body starts to naturally relax your
heart rate starts to naturally decrease
and then your brain starts to reduce the
amount of stress chemicals that it's
going to be emitting out into your
system that's a good one another breath
cycle that has been researched time and
time again to help with HRV and it's
specifically given to people with PTSD
and that people that are prone to panic
attacks is inhaling through the nose for
a count of four pausing for a count of
two and then exhaling out the mouth for
a count of six and pausing for two and
so you do that cycle
again for four five six minutes and what
actually happens is that when you exhale
longer on the exhale than you do on the
inhale that compression slows down the
heart rate naturally right so it
actually slows down the heart rate over
time and decreases stress within the
body and it sort of not forces but
naturally causes your body to move into
a more parasympathetic calm oriented
state it might feel challenging at first
a lot of people that that have high
levels of anxiety and high levels of
stress for the first 60 to 120 seconds
it's probably going to be like ah this
is super labored it's challenging it's
hard but that's the point is that you're
interfering with your body with your
body's normal patterns right because for
most people the more stressed they are
the more anxious they are the faster
they're breathing right the more
unconscious unconscious they are with
their breath and the faster that they're
breathing so your breath is the first
part
the second part of how you can start to
de-stress
is prioritizing things that are
uncomfortable but you're choosing that
discomfort right so this is why Cold
immersion is a is a very big uh there's
a big push for it because what's
happening when you're doing that is
you're putting your body into a natural
stress State and you are calming
yourself under that duress so it's like
a training ground for you to actually
like put yourself into a naturally
stressed State even if you just want to
do a cold shower right if you're not
like I don't want to go jump into an
Arctic you know lake or river sure just
do a warm shower and at the end of the
cold shower turn it at the end of the
hot shower turn it to cold as cold as
you can take it for about 60 seconds
regulate your breath focus in on your
breath right because your breath's going
to want to go like
you go
you know like that's kind of what you do
when you get that cold because you just
you you realize you're getting out of
control yeah so that and there's a ton
of benefits to this right and this is
um you know there was a study that
showed that just by taking a 60-second
cold shower every single day the people
in the study to reduce the amount of six
days sick days that they were taking by
30 to 40 percent within it within a
single year right so it's actually
helping your body regulate it's
decreasing inflammation it's uh
balancing out the pH levels within your
body which is a very important thing
because the more acidic your body is the
more inflamed it is and then the more
volatile you are right if you like this
clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen